[Music]
when you speak we listen move them move
the codes let's do it
they're really making this tough on me
now we'll see what he's really got
[Music]
it is cold and i feel good welcome to
underrated i'm adam lefkow behind me is
the cat alex the brink hat a young
rising star for the chicago blackhawks
third leading scorer in the nhl last
season and we want to know how he looks
in nhl 22 what x factors does he bring
we got our pro gamer nasher to take a
look
what i'm looking for in a left winger is
somebody that's speedy they can go up
and down the ice no problem at all make
that move and not just score goals but
score nasty goals as well and i feel
like that's what adb does best he's got
make it snappy so he has the ability to
just go up and down the ice again when
you have those defenders in front of you
you want to be able to quickly make that
move and he's the one that can do it
[Music]
when you were playing nhl games growing
up who was your team
who was the squad yeah definitely
detroit
huge redwings fan growing up and would
you play a lot uh yeah i liked nhl a lot
yeah we just heard from our pro gamer
nasher that you have a very important x
factor that not everyone else has make
it snappy the ability to get off
that wrist shot super quick
i'm here today to make sure
that you still deserve it
so we've got a little defense set up
here and i mean little we need you to
skate through our defenders and take a
shot on goal you get six chances to
explode two of our targets if you can
get two of those things you've proven
you deserve the make it snappy x factor
you're cool yeah yeah that's cool the
cat is on the ice let's do it
[Music]
all right which which target you going
for first top left top left yeah in
three
two
one
the cat weaving in
almost destroyed the goalie in the face
to bring cats
that was two inches
two inches
to bring cat weaves in
boom
that's how it's done and you see it's
like i played hockey i knew it like you
do little knuckles
that felt good how did it feel that felt
good that felt good see i think this
should be hockey all the time you
scoring confetti explodes okay there's
one
i'm going top right yeah that's probably
man likes top shelf top right the brink
cat wants two let's make it snappy
oh
this is the last one whenever you're
ready man
got this bro
here he goes he has one he needs the
second one
[Music]
boom nailed it not only did you nail it
oh man i'm proud of you take a look what
you just did
[Music]
oh
i almost bit
dang
make it snappy bang
i'm not giving this back though i'm
proud of you
that's the big x factor i'm keeping this
yeah tell us crosby to eat it
perfect
so obviously alex is a smaller guy in
the nhl but he doesn't let that bring
him down he's able to utilize his speed
and of course that ankle breaker make
his way up the ice quick move can get
the shot and we can bury the goal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so you did phenomenal in the
make it snappy but now it is time for
the ankle breaker drill you're gonna go
through i need to see
quickness you can't lose speed but you
got to break some ankles i'm not
qualified to judge this would you agree
yeah it would have been great awesome
but i have someone that is the greatest
that's ever done it
wayne gretzky the great one
all right let's see what you got i'm so
excited
what are we looking for wayne what are
we what are you looking for well first
of all you want to look for balance and
you have to have speed
that's the hard combination to keep the
balance and speed together so if you can
keep the balance and the speed you'll be
fine but it's a hard one this is a tough
one to do
do you want to ask any advice do you
want to say anything to him uh no i
think i'll just give it a go
he's gonna give it a go
wayne are you ready to judge i i don't i
don't want you to be soft i want harsh
criticism i i i will be awesome all
right gretzky let's do this you got a
cat
all right cat
keep the speed break some ankles
whenever you're ready man
here he does
easy easy work easy work
[Music]
now i see why he was third in goals
hey
man that was good okay let's go with a
great one what did you think from what
you saw
well first of all you guys brought in a
ringer technique was really good he was
upright yet balanced he had great uh
mobility he was strong he was fast he it
was really good were the ankles broken
like if you were a defender would he
have broken your ankles well i wasn't a
very good defender so probably right
i i wanted to better go i was better
going the other way yeah i didn't really
do much backing up we should move the
cones to make it harder for them how
would you like to bring them my grandson
could go through those cones and he's
five and he lives in florida so you need
to stagger the cones so he has to kind
of go in and out that's how we're gonna
see
if he has agility and balance together
stagger the cones when you speak we
listen move them move the cones let's do
it
they're really making this tough on me
now we'll see what he's really got we
need one more cone where he's standing
can we you know what can we get one of
you guys just to stand there
yeah yeah you can stand there oh man all
right
see that's what a good host does he's
versatile wayne's making it tough man
you're the first cone here we go you
know you know for someone that said oh
he did a great job you really got a lot
of suggestions for this one well
i want to see i want to see if he's
really good okay deal
we have the suggestions from the great
one i am now a prop and we are gonna see
the cat in action whenever you're ready
man
[Music]
wow wow wow oh my god
hey
ah
oh my goodness
and he drills the goalie in the face
see
come on come on wayne
okay he's really good and i i knew he
was good that's why i wanted to make it
more difficult yeah that was really good
he bent his shoulders down when he
leaned in and kept it up the other way
when he went the other way he had his
stick turned properly
i got to tell you it was really good
what i just want to know what is it like
to hear that ah that's crazy i mean
obviously the great one telling you that
um
you know shows you some accomplishment
and hopefully i can get this ankle
breaker i love it all right so now wayne
i'll ask you in your mind should he keep
the ankle breaker
yes
and you are
a great pylon so this is a win-win
you know that's what i've been working
to my entire life was for that moment
wow how about that it's crazy i one
i was a little bit nervous that you were
gonna run me over and now i experience
that speed firsthand
uh tore up the drill
you keep the ankle breaker but that last
compliment for me i feel like that's
something that i would hold for a while
yeah for sure congratulations thank you
the cat in action the claws are out
man he almost run me over jeez
you